[Music]
right everybody thank you
you continue the
committee meeting thank you
our next application is application 7d
and
they launched great
[Music]
the youtube stream
uh online everyone hear me okay yeah
okay uh as the chair said this is
application one forward slash
one four slash twenty twenty
four star chef iran's the erection of um
one residential dwelling following the
uh
existing structure on the site uh the
site is at
land a great film farm partnering devon
it's actually just to the site of
the uh
um
just a couple of updates for members
today um
further to uh the submission of revised
circulation tests the environmental
protection officers have been he's happy
with those
um this
was happened sort of after the draft in
the report so
um so it's just officer's advice to
members that you can disregard the
recommended um reason for refusal number
three which related to foul drainage
environment protection officers they're
happy with that
um we've also received a further
objection uh which
development was undertaken and by the
applicants as well as inaccuracies in
respect to the current application to be
considered today and i understand that
the injector has also registered to
speak today she will be
a speaker just a really a point of note
for members the the
way that previous developments have been
undertaken by the applicants is not a
matter of consideration um for members
today and should have given any weight
in in their consideration
uh next slide visual
uh so this shows the site location plan
and a couple of aerial images as well on
the left hand side and the center
and we can see the site there on the
left hand side show outlined in red
and on the aerial image that red arrow
shows the site there
it's enclosed on three sides by hedge
bank and trees
uh accommodates an existing structure
relating to a previous permission which
i'll come back to in a minute
uh we've got a grass area to the north
and then finland lane and then great
film farm
and then over to the north as well we've
got the
hamlet of film
which essentially
comprises a small collection of
agricultural buildings holiday labs and
dwellings
uh to the east of the site we've got the
private parking garden area associated
with great finland house which is
heartland is situated about 1.5
kilometers to the north
it's also worth noting that the site is
located within the aomb and drops away
from its northern to its southern edge
before
dropping further into a valley
the
the image on the right hand side just
shows the relationship of the site which
is the red arrow in relation to um
[Music]
just coming back to the existing
structure on the site it's worth just
probably just taking it through quickly
through the history on the site in 1993
the council granted outline planning
commission and reserve matters approval
for
an agriculturally tied dwelling that had
the standard agricultural occupancy
condition on it that's actually applied
to agricultural weather dwellings
but that permission then lapsed
and their development then commenced
after it lapsed and so without the
benefit of planning permission there
the
2002 then we had an application to
retain that structure which was then
refused by the council
in 2014 we had um another application
for the completion of development as a
news as a holiday that that was also
refused
uh and the reasons for that was that it
was an unsustainable location
within the countryside and also the harm
to the the designated aomb
um
in terms of landscape character
december 21
um obviously just five months ago we
don't have a further application for the
erection and dwelling
that was withdrawn by the applicants
following advice from the officer at the
time that it was to be refused of the
delegated powers again because of the
unsustainable location of the site
uh and the harm to the aomp
so
to summarize all of that basically the
development of obviously has commenced
without planning permission is not a
substantially completed dwelling in that
or is not immune enforcement action so
what we're looking at there is basically
an unauthorized structure on the site
so in terms of members deliberation of
this application it is it's quite
important to know that what you're
considering is a greenfield site really
and so
in your office's view there shouldn't be
weight given to the removal of that
structure
as much as it may be an eyesore
apparently um because probably you would
be unauthorized
um it's also just worth noting that the
current proposal is for an open market
residential dwelling there's no
suggestion that it would be
agriculturally tied as was permitted
back in 1993 and it's just a normal open
mind
the only other point i supposed to know
is that what is now proposed is a
different building to what is partially
constructed so it's not it's not that
this would be carried on as a building
operation maintenance as well and this
would be removed from the site new
dwelling
constructed
um just to point on the right-hand side
as well
you can obviously see the relationship
of the site to heartland
it's just worth noting that really the
the highway to get back to heartland
until you reach the b234a
is is a narrow devon lane really with no
pavements no street lights
with the result obviously the majority
of journeys would be likely to be made
by by private car
next location
[Music]
so this is the existing and proposed
block plan is fairly self-explanatory on
the left we have the existing
uh which shows the
outline of the existing um structure on
there and on the right hand side we have
the proposed dwellings footprint parking
areas of the north uh draw up driveway
and access also to the north across the
existing grass area
and the provision of a new hedge bank
on the western boundary
and upside visual
uh proposed elevations uh the external
materials natural stone and depth of
coins
um to the external walls and that's
beneath a
uh roof covering of natural slate um you
can also see on the southern elevation
there which is the top top
image
some solar panels there as well
and that would be the south elevation
that would be facing out into the across
the valley
uh next location
is just the other elevations on the top
we've got the north elevation which will
be facing back towards great finland
farm
and uh and beneath that the west
elevation
and it's slightly sure
uh the top is just a proposed section
and then at the bottom there on the on
the left hand side we have the ground
floor got two bedrooms
on the ground floor one bedroom first
floor level and then a kitchen dining
room a ground floor and a living room
level
and then next slide facial
this is photographs of the site the top
two are
photographs of the existing unauthorized
structure on the site
bottom left uh is looking south through
the existing gateway the sun was
actually shining back into the camera
but you can just about to see the
outline of the existing structure there
bottom middle is looking out across the
valley
and into the aomb and just on the right
hand side there you can see the corner
of the existing unauthorized structure
and the bottom right is just taken from
the western side of the site again
looking out across the valley there you
can still see an agricultural
field adjacent to the site that
next slide
the top two are taken within this site
looking north back towards um great
villain farm
bottom left we have finland lane
looking east
and um
bottom middle we have um
the site on the left hand side and then
great film farm on the on the right hand
side there's a holiday left there
i think this this is one of the most
notable points about the area really
you've got these
tightly
banked devon highways that you approach
the site from from the north very
enclosed sort of field
classic classic devon highway and then
you come around the corner and then the
site really does open up and then it's
quite apparent in your offices for you
anyway that you've got
the
all of the built form on the on the left
hand side of the north which is the
existing hamlet and then you've got
quite clearly defined character of them
lane this grassed area mature trees and
then and then the site there and it does
really into it in your office's view you
sort of feel that the site is quite
divorced from that existing um
arrangement it's quite a strong
character there that that happens really
from approaching from both both sides
really i mean
the highway does enclose the hamlet
really and when you come down and
whether you're looking at it from the
east or the west it's then you get that
impression really
and then just bottom right that's a just
a photograph of the highway um between
the site and heartland um as i said
before there's no pavements no street
lighting um and it's likely to encourage
all journeys to be made by my private
car
uh let's like sean
um top left is just a photo of the
access um into the parking and
uh garden area associated with the um
bed of breakfast and this that is
located to
the east to the site
and then the other images
are taken from long-distance views
basically from a highway which is to the
south and these are also the design and
access statement as well
and and this shows um the red arrows at
the site really
and it it's from the highway really that
it provides access to probably to
tossberry and edison i think and
um and i think from your office's point
of view it is clear that you do see the
site within the context of the existing
grouping of
um
buildings that the great finn and palm
really so
there's a concern from officers in terms
of the impact of those long-distance
views it's all about
the more localized impacts really
and next slide you're sure
so just material considerations
principal development and there's no
market dwelling in the countryside
it's contrary to policies st06 sg07 it's
departure from the local plan
it's been advertised as a departure
um as i said earlier mr officer's view
that no weight should be given to the
removal of the existing structure
because it's unauthorized
um and
and so yeah it is it is
not supported in in terms of the
principle of development really by
adopting policy
character appearance
um again as well as previously really
it's considered by your officers with
the psychological leads and the existing
built form of film
it is located within the aomb
um and
and obviously
in your offices view representing
congress addition to that existing built
form
residential amenity um
you'll know that there's there's a
objection um from a local
member of the public who raises concerns
about
the potential for um uh
adverse impacts on their water supply
because most people on
that way are on poor hole
from it's a different one from the
office point of view i think it is
obviously a serious concern but it's
about i think how you evidence
that this development would adversely
impact that and i think from your
office's point of view there's not
sufficient evidence to warrant a reason
for refusal that albeit as i said it
would be a matter of concern if that was
to be
an advanced impact
in terms of biodiversity there's a baton
nesting birds who have been submitted
that demonstrates that there'll be no
obvious impact
in highways terms the site is remote
from services and facilities necessary
to support a residential use
that will encourage private car use
really to access all services um which
is contrary to
the aims of the local plan and also
national guidance in terms of reducing
um private car and
[Music]
uh
journeys
terms of the power and surface water no
concerns there at all that's fine
um
obviously members will be aware
familiar with the the situation that the
council can't demonstrate five years
supply companies necessary to undertake
the tilted balance
and your officer's view there is only a
modest benefit see from the provision of
one single dwelling
um so previously no weight is given to
the removal of the structure given it's
unauthorized
there's also
the design access statement does detail
um
several personal circumstances of the
applicants in terms of their involvement
in the local community etc that's that's
all seem
all well and good but doesn't form part
of the material consideration in
consideration of the planning
application
and then so in terms of the other side
of that balance really this harm to the
character appearance of the a1b
and uh and the sustainability aims of
the local plan and national guardians
really due to the increased use of
private motor vehicles and
so for those reasons the european
officers conclude that the adverse
impacts would significantly demonstrably
outweigh
the benefits and therefore has
recommended the planning permission to
be refused
and if there's any questions at all
thank you can you just ask one question
before you hear me yeah of course
you went through the planning history
yeah you said it i've got it in front of
this in 2002
they tried to retain the partially
distracted
running that was refused
but they never took it down we didn't
enforce that no i mean we've looked at
this
looked into this a lot it doesn't it
is clear from um notes on other
applications that enforcement officers
did visit the site
and that works in stock but it doesn't
appear that we've only taken formal
enforcement action
um we've also i think
one or two of the objections do
um suggest that there was a demolition
order on the site
uh again there's no record of a
demolition order it probably would be
it wouldn't be a planning matter anyway
um but i can't find it there's no record
of a land charge on the site and so
off this point you've got to conclude
that no formal actions been taken
but that wouldn't include action being
taken forward obviously because it does
remain unauthorized
[Music]
right thank you for that [ __ ] james
thanks for the presentation
the our first speaker speaking against
the application is brenda
if you can put the microphone over there
gems for the oven speakers
[Music]
once you're settled if you speak right
into the end of the microphone please
and then we can hear you everybody can
be
when you're ready you've got three
minutes
thank you um could i just say on that
last point about
mission to the microphone as could i
just say on that last point that it was
richard walter who told me
the farmer who had been given the
original commission in 1993
he said he had he had been told he'd got
to take it down
that's
not just
and
when i submitted my
um online comment and before i did i
phoned planning support
and they said yes it is in time the
committee report the planning office's
report had not yet been included so i
was originally
before
mr jackson's
report i have timed this to be three
minutes so
um
if you're with your approval i'd like to
read it
i do have copies for the council and for
the applicants
i wish to provide the legal grounds
for my concern about this application
firstly
the applicant's borehole
is unlawful under section 6 of the water
act 2003
because it is outside the cartilage of
their property
the agents tried to conceal this breach
the ball is missing on their block plan
they also misconstrue the land next to
the proposed site
as an extended grass verge
when the land is protected
registered common land
under the council's jurisdiction
the applicant certainly
as the enforcement officer mr marshall
had previously advised them that their
concrete path on the common land had to
be removed
on page 18 of the design access
statement
the agents reveal the war home
on the protected land
the iron study cover of lamar water
services is at the forefront of the
first world
i now turn to section 24 of the housing
act 1988 that allows a house to be built
on farmland
in 4.9 of the design access statement
the agents say the proposal is based on
the location
of the 1993 approved dwelling
farmer
so on page seven
they display
they display the successful plans for
farmer richard water this is their
attempted precedent for the new build
requiring them repeatedly to name the
site as great film farm
in contradiction to the applicants
declaring freehold ownership in the
application form
the apple applicants cannot possibly
meet the conditions of occupancy
they are not in they are not in
full-time agricultural employment
there is no functional need in the new
build to tend livestock
and they cannot verify a preceding
successful farm business
my third and last concern
is misrepresentation
in 3.8 of the design access statement
the applicants say the power is a
derelict barn
this is not true
the council's records show
that the parlor was already fit for bed
and breakfast accommodation in 1987
with more facilities such as the
swimming pool an extra bedroom etc
granted in 1988 and 1999.
in
2007
the applicant's
own agent s j proudslip design stated
that the existing
external natural stone and brick coins
would be retained
would actually wind up now please
this is the last sentence yet the agents
for this proposal in 4.5 and 4.6 of the
design statement
and the photo on page 10
pretend that it is the applicant's idea
thank you thank you
[Music]
our next contribution is diana and paul
mccarroll
and they sent an email in which our
planning
manager will read
you chair can you remember to hear me
yeah
there's a statement from diana and
former carol
we are unable to be at the meeting on
the 14th of april as planned due to my
husband's ill health i would appreciate
your officer readings very important
issue on our behalf
we have lived in philharm hamlet for
over 20 years
and as commented on this application we
wish to reiterate our very serious
concerns about the water demands in the
hamlet of fulham
the dairy farm in close proximity has
since 2017 increased its sizable water
consumption
attention should be
should be drawn to the heartland parish
council's comments regarding committed
application 1-0 852-2017
sinclair's farm for them which states
the possible increase in agricultural
activity could affect locally sourced
water supplies of those living in close
proximity
most of the dwellers in the hamilton
film depend on boreholes for source of
water supply
one house bartholomew's which is
adjacent to the coast site has no water
at all and two other houses nearby
experience water sources in dry periods
great filling holiday lens which is
directly opposite we ran out of water
which was needed for its guests and how
to add extra boreholes
we've got new developments in film if
the council would allay our very real
concerns this would be reassuring to all
of us who live in the hamlet film even
though provision will be made to catch
and store rain water on the proposed new
building a new building we question the
capacity limitations on a construction
of this substantial size with so many
ensuite and water consumption facilities
thank you diana and paul mccarroll
thank you sean
[Music]
our next speaker is james knee who's the
agent for the site
and once you settle you've got three
minutes to address the commitment okay
thanks very much
okay so
the site is bordered to the east and to
the north by residential land and
properties and to the south and west
with defined hedge funds separating
residential and agricultural zones of
film
mapping and satellite imagery
demonstrated two zones and were included
as part of the significant documents
the large partially built dwelling
whether constructed legally or not has
been present on the site for over 20
years
as such it is arguable that the site in
fact does connect to film and can be
considered as an infield rounding off of
an existing settlement
with regards to the sustainability of
the location and reliance on private
vehicles
the partially built dwelling originally
obtained planning permission as a
two-story three-bedroom agricultural
workers wedding clearly designed to
accommodate a family
this demonstrates that the site was
considered a sustainable location for a
dwelling with one family member working
on-site
either supporting their family entirely
or most likely with other family members
traveling to places of work from this
location
that is exactly what's proposed for this
planning because mrs brown has a
successful dressmaking business which
she has always operated from home but
her current property does not provide
suitable space
new dwelling provides crucial additional
space to allow mrs brian to continue the
operation of the business from home
without this she will need to commute
the proposal therefore qualifies and
meets criteria set out in for a local
needs dwelling which has provision under
current policy to be granted in rural
areas such as this
it should also be noted that people's
shopping habits have changed especially
since the pandemic both in urban and
rural areas it's now common for
suppliers and groceries to be delivered
which is more efficient in further
reducing private car usage
the site lies in the area of outstanding
natural beauty and the current decaying
half-built dwelling has a huge negative
visual impact on this whether legally
built or not
the new locally appropriate design
material selection instead enhances the
aomb
and the existing material trees provide
good screening from closer distances and
maintain the current street scene
the proposal meets all other
requirements for dwelling with safe
access to the public highway sustainable
drainage provision demonstrated by the
latest speculation tests
use of sensitive materials and no
negative ecological impacts
the site presents a unique set of
circumstances and an opportunity to
replace a partially built visually
damaging dwelling on a sustainable site
it therefore does not set precedent for
other dwellings to be granted in the
area as there are no other sites
presenting an opportunity for
improvement like this
by supporting this application you're
providing a dwelling supporting a local
family with local needs
contributing to the five-year housing
supply that we cannot currently
demonstrate
and making a positive improvement to the
aonb
thank you very much thank you
and our next speaker in support of the
application anthony brumman
once your
the previous applications for the site
had nothing to do with me just one at
the end of last year at the smart
previous owner so please don't associate
me with lots of applications on this
site
lorraine and i have lived in berlin for
40 years as an area of outstanding
natural beauty we spent these years
significantly enhancing the village by
renovating breakfast house
sympathetically converting the attached
barn and derelict stable block and
reconstructing a long stretch of dry
stone walling ordered which has
substantially improved the appearance of
fillum as viewed from the surrounding
countryside
we are looking to further enhance this
area by replacing an existing eyesore of
a partly constructed house with a
sympathetically constructed natural
stone placed environmentally preying
property
this is very much a request for a local
needs dwelling where larry and i intend
to live the remains of our lives
the house will include a dress making
studio from which my wife will continue
her dressmaking business
and this will provide a valuable service
as it currently does to many locals
over the years we have supported
heartland through membership of the pta
the governors the atc
village hall
cubs carnival committee and i still
represent the atc and the clinical
committees
granting planning for local needs will
enable a small business to continue to
service the local area
and will enable us to contribute to the
wider community
location we do not agree that we are in
open countryside or extending the
village boundary the aerial photograph
in our application clearly shows a
natural boundary and this building lies
within it in fact besides we started
with you can see the boundaries the box
has not been used for agricultural
purposes for over 30 years the land of
jason is 100
residential having been used as a
private garden for the last 20 years
however we have placed the covenant on
that adjacent land to prevent any
further residential building
we believe that this strip of land is
clearly residential and therefore within
the village boundary the plot is service
um
through access and we are intending to
have a rainwater collection system so
has got to drain on the water supplies
planning has previously been granted for
a three-bedroom house on this site
sustainability there is excellent access
to heartland town and easy access to the
a39 all of which satisfactorily service
finland the road on our doorstep is
fully serviced by recycling waste
collection school buses and the
community call and collect service which
all stop in the hamlets there have never
been any delivery issues or access to
film and we regularly walk and cycle to
heartland which is only just over one
mile away
support we have had no objections within
the deadline from this village from
heartland or parish from the powerland
parish council
on the contrary our one person we have
had the full support of all the
residents in finland and the surrounding
area
we have included in our pack 13 letters
of support which are in the application
which came from 14 requests sent to our
neighbours and that includes diane
mackerel who wasn't speaking today but
on her online submission she starts with
the class that she gives her us her full
support her concerns water and we've
looked to allay that
and actually
to summarize we're not distracting from
but enhancing at the area of expansion
outstanding natural duty we are not
extending the british boundary the
houses fulfill a major local housing
need which will benefit the local
community it doesn't set a president
it's environmentally friendly
sympathetically designed and has the
full support of local residents and
councillors and is one more property
towards the torres county plan
i'm asking you please today to draw a
positive
[Music]
thank you
our final speaker to this application is
board member counselor and adult
thank you for letting me speak
james's report was extremely well
prepared and succinct
and honestly i'm struggling to argue the
sustainability issues raised within it
yes a car will be required when living
at this residence
yes it is in the hamlet and not the main
covered village
however
what i can argue is a consistency of
approach
let me read you if i may and extract
that the applicant wrote laura davies
prior to withdrawing the application in
the first instance
[Music]
planning has recently been granted
um i won't need to reference that but
there are an old raf building nearby
city corner
notwithstanding the restrictions placed
on it as the old building is of
historical interest this property is a
derelict building in aonb in
agricultural land is on the outside of
the village boundary has no previous
planning or residential use
in order to maintain consistency we
would suggest that the plot of film is
virtually identical in principle to this
i have also attached the original
planning application for film showing
that commission was granted to erect a
three-bedroom detached property on this
piece of land in 1993
had that construction been completed
there would be a property standing here
and preston has therefore been set
as it is there is a half-built property
which is in fact detracting from the air
and b
we have no further new evidence to offer
but would like to reinforce the key
aspects of our application
the property is to satisfy the local
needs of a local family wishing to
return to film there are limited to no
other options that will allow us to do
this when we embarked on this project we
never considered the possibility of the
application being declined especially as
it has the full support of residents in
the hamlet previously
have planning on it and a new property
will greatly enhance the look of the
handling itself
the local parish has not made any
objections although commented on the new
footprint
it does add to the touch building stock
the design materials are in keeping with
the surrounding area being constructed
with ecology in mind and a cover net has
been placed on the adjoining land to
prevent further building
it will be a major visual improvement to
the village and the land has not been
used for agricultural purposes in over
30 years and will not be used for
agriculture in the future therefore
rendering it wasteland
the points the applicants makes are
worthy of consideration
indeed i can name various examples
whereby residential commissions have
been granted in unsustainable locations
this is presumably because they are all
addressed on their own merits so let's
look at the merits of this site
well firstly the air and b
unusually have no objection they haven't
commented
which speaks volumes
and this site sits next to the
residential garden cartilage so it
simply extends this line as is shown on
these aerial photos here
secondly if granted the economic
benefits build costs and materials boost
tourist businesses
county tax boosters budgets household
and day-to-day living expenditure boost
towards economy
thirdly the locality residents and
friends and customers get to welcome
back the couple that currently living
over the border in cornwall
they come back into devon the couple are
committed to their community
they've involved themselves tirelessly
with the heartland atc providing a much
needed boost to our young people by this
excellent corporation
unfortunately the site itself and here
we need to keep it real
nigel marshall will try for years to get
this building demolished to no avail
i know because i work with him on it
if this permission is not granted ask
yourselves do we really
have the resource both the persons and
the finance resource
to
get this building this answer removed
will we even bother
it looks sad it drags down the
surrounding area
to conclude i'll simply say this there
has been a commission granted on this
site historically
it should be granted now if ever there
was a time it should be granted now
we have a housing crisis soon to be
followed by an economic crisis
there are positives in granting this
application let's grab at those
positives if you can overcome the
restrictive
sustainability policy i urge you please
to do so
thank you
[Music]
much was made by the agent and the
advocate
that they are applying for local needs
but this application is for residential
trending and if
if it was password over these one and it
would need a lot more conditions on it
for its resale and
the application actually is for an open
market dwelling it hasn't been mentioned
previously that this is a local needs
proposal and clearly the the assessment
by your officers would be
quite different to that that has been
undertaken really so we've been looking
at policy dm
24.
that policy sort of includes a number of
criteria that we would need to
be satisfied that the applicant met and
nothing clearly that assessment hasn't
been undertaken at this time really so
um one of the one of the key points of
um 24 is that it relates to rural
settlements and they are defining the
plan as
some settlements that have one
particular facility such as a pub or a
church or something like that so
in terms of film that wouldn't actually
qualify as a rural settlement anyway it
is a countryside countryside location in
terms of the local plan
and as you correctly state the council
there would be a requirement for a
section 106 agreement to tie it up
because
so yeah we simply haven't made that
assessment at all
so would that necessitate then the fresh
application of to apply for a local
needs to end
uh i think you would pro it would need
to be re-advertised as such i would
imagine yes yeah okay
cancel questions yeah thank you it's one
of the points i was going to raise
actually but
there's a problem here isn't there that
there's a very messy
planning history on this site and i i
feel for the applicant when he said it's
nothing to do with me i'm afraid it is
unfortunate we're talking about the site
we're not talking about the africans
having said that this was only around
what for nearly 30 years ago as an
agricultural workers dwelling and even
back then the criteria were pretty
strict
we know that how you know how difficult
it was to get an agricultural workers
dwelling um
it was as our officer has said uh it was
built illegally
that's the word he used
um it should have been removed and i'm
afraid you know torres is at fought
there
um having said that uh i was slightly
puzzled by the
fact it suddenly became a local knees
dwelling where it is clearly open market
and
it seems to be about a business which
you know that's not local needs as such
but um
we have to ask ourselves as the officer
said we've got to treat this as a
greenfield site
would we give permission today
for a house in the open countryside on a
greenfield site and we know we probably
wouldn't
and it's all very well saying well there
are ruins there
well that's not the problem they're
there illegally and you can't say all
right we'll make it legal now by doing
this
so i feel
unfortunately i can't support this as it
stands if they want to come back as a
local needs housing
then they've got to obviously fulfill
the criteria for that but i think would
be much better way to go so i'm going to
propose at the moment
i'll support coach i'll support that
anybody else
if
the application was approved could we
remove permitted development rights from
the rest of the field
in terms of the wider agricultural field
or yeah
i think you could only really relate it
to this development so you could remove
the pd rights in terms of this
development but but not wider than that
i think it'd probably have to be up to
an article for direction or something
like that which one might be terrifying
[Music]
right nobody else want to come in
but
i did look
i think as everybody else has them very
close at this application
when you look up go on google and look
at it and look at the area
it is a blight on the area as it is
currently
let go like that
um whether whether torridge would bother
now doing anything about that science i
don't know really
it's um
it's probably been applied for in the
wrong context if it should be local
needs to i mean
as there planning office has said we
need a different application
to consider that
um
but i do accept that
the sustainability issue is one thing
we all know that people walk miles along
country lady
you live in devon you need a car you
live in our area you need a car and they
helped in with it today
if you really do so
i do have some problems with their
sustainability
uh because a car is essential in this
area
but it's been moved to refused by
council christian
and seconded by councillor watson
[Music]
um i think the applicant should be
encouraged to reapply
under a local needs dwelling
not be discouraged if this is refused
but encourage them to apply again for
local needs
i think yeah they can have that
conversation with can i just make one
clear point as well i think just
not necessarily related to this because
obviously this is an experiences
proposal but one of the key things about
the local needs dwelling as well would
be
in terms of um that actual operational
need as well in terms of that business
if they're trying to tie it to the
business we don't know any details of
that at this stage so i think that
that's fine to
they could obviously make an application
in the future but
just to stress again really we haven't
made any assessment of the merits about
this time really
could an
application be
to make an application for that and we
just have something to notice no problem
[Music]
um i just think it's worth tripping
about local needs it's quite a
tremendous point really um the purpose
about local needs is to meet a locally
identified housing need
so it's not necessarily the applicant
it's that mentally identified housing
needs and that needs to be demonstrated
as well
so as the officer is quite rough that
there's lots of different avenues that
need to be considered in a local
i mean the only thing i would say on
that balance that
james mentioned because you've not got
the five-year housing land supply
it's accepting
that you give planning permission
normally
on this balance if
what you're proposing will not have any
substantial harm to the area
and it's a difficult one though it's a
difficult one
in
that respect with this application
and
of course
it is refused by this committee to take
it to appeal and
that's the problem
right senator
please
thank you chad cancer
for
cancer
[Music]
good
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
right
right we move on into our next
application
agenda item 7a
and ryan bryan you're presenting this
application
[Music]
thank you chair of our chair good
morning to you all
good morning
so i'll first start with a verbal update
to the application so i'll see following
committee site visits the council
received a minor amendment to the site
plan
uh which indicates that there will be
real access to 17 and 17 a barton tools
[Music]
the first slide shows the site location
um
which is located on the bend within sort
of barton tours which is a through road
between gamington road at the central
corner to the north
and obviously
as we go through the slides you'll see
the sort of surrounding green
development which is characterized by
mainly semi-saturated and terrorist
properties
that's vital
again that just this this is a sort of
close-up of that sort of google
satellite imagery and obviously you can
see the site is sort of located south of
17 barton tours
and and so to the uh west of 16 barton
tours in that relationship of as i said
the
existing semi-status properties and then
obviously the terrorist properties to 16
onwards next slideshow
this is a site plan again uh it's a
survey story and it just sort of shows
the existing um
composition on the site i.e
existing concrete areas and existing
driveways etc
next election
again this is this this is the amended
site plan so as you can see we've now
had that annotated to show that they've
been accessed the 1778 pay party tools
obviously
the site plan also indicates
uh
in stores to the north of the site and a
total of four car car parking spaces and
can we zoom in sure
eastern part of the site so you can see
three parking spaces
or eastern side yeah then the
landscaping sort below that and which
includes an indigenous digital
hedge
and then at one parking space to the
south
[Music]
this is the ground floor plan each floor
provides 61
meters square of accommodation the
ground floor plan includes two bedrooms
an open plan kitchen lounge area and a
bathroom as well as being um
internal storage
and this is the first floor plan which
is replicates that sort of ground floor
area
this is the southwest elevation which is
the front elevation you can see
and
yeah you can see the front elevation
here and how it relates to the um
sort of 17 uh bathroom tours which is
the jason dwelling
and
i think during the community
there was reference to the sort of
height in relation to ceramic properties
there i have measured it although not
completely accurate but there is one one
meter difference between that sort of
front cable
and as it sort of lifts up from on front
elevation as you can see there
looks like sean
this is the
northeast elevation which is the rear
elevation
extension
and this is the southeastern ocean so
this is side elevation obviously you can
see it includes the bird box on that
elevation and this is the start of the
elevation which faces or would face uh
the road from spartan sources
and this is the north north west
elevation which is
a section drawing which you know
if you could
take it the perspective from
17 and 18 basis towards looking back
towards towards the
application site you can see
opaque glazing which serves bathrooms at
ground floor and first floor level
this is a 3d model showing the street
scene it shows the relationship of the
um
the development alongside the
surrounding sort of built form and i've
sort of included sort of map from the
top right of the drawing which indicates
where this position is taken from so
this position is taken from the approach
from garrison road and sort of faces um
west
and as we move through the slides there
are other 3d models which might help
and yeah and this is from sort of you
know coming from central corner the
north anything
down towards the application sites the
application site is on your left then
you can see how that front cable
relates to the yes around the journal
next slide and this is looking directly
towards the application site
[Music]
here we have some photos
of the site uh
of the surrounding roads so on the
left-hand side this is the
road which is directed towards uh
central to the north um
and then the right image we have
uh this is sort of heading back towards
downtown the application site on the
left
next slide
this is an image uh directly of the
application site and so on the left
image
includes the sort of side elevation of
17 barton tools
and then so it's all pounds across
almost like panoramic image and that
includes the rest of the site including
the boundary fencing and their 16 barton
tools which is the sort of cream color
dwelling
i now have an array of images from
within the site itself so obviously this
is
these images taken at different times
you might be able to tell which one
accounts for whether um
but the site includes yes this is within
the site and looking to the top uh to
the east of the site
and then these are images which include
socks the side of elevation of cement
and advantage tools
and the image on the left is within the
app page looking at that side elevation
and sort of back towards the side
and the
right image is of the rear immunity area
of 17 bottom tools
the following images are taken from um
eighteen barton tools the mean tier of
eight embassy tours and can be used to
assess the impact that might be caused
as a result of this development
and so this is a expected drawing taken
uh from 18 barton tours to looking south
back towards the application site and
the road and showing the relationship to
other dwellings
next slide
this is a sort of slight image left
really i'm showing again
the sort of relationship of other
dwellings with this land
including their fenestration form in
relation to the applications that would
appear on the right hand side
and this is
a view looking into the sort of further
rear or facing bottom tools and and the
media and again just indicates the
ceramic form
and design
and this is
back within 18 tools looking back
towards six um
looking back towards 17 bartender tools
which is also the lighter rendered
property there and and then obviously
you've got a 16 on the left hand side
and looking directly back to the
application side
the main considerations of this
application are principal development
character appearance impact community
highways access to parking drone
supervision and ecology and your officer
recommends approval thank you
thank you ryan
and the first remember what if you put
the microphone there
best speaker against this application is
[Music]
i am the resident and also the owner of
another 18 barton tours that joins
number 17 with proposals for the third
one in fact the other two were refused
um i want to respond to the committee
report written on 31st march that
actually recommends approving this from
the don't agree it states there are five
matters and five objections there is
actually a petition of 10 different
households amount of smaller than 10
people that have objected which has been
submitted and have a copy if for some
reason people haven't seen it and then
six residents wrote in not five and
they're all up on the website the whole
community feels incredibly strongly
against
this proposal
two reasons i'm not listed in the report
for some reason is the fact that it
turns my house from a semi-detached to a
terrorist property and devalues my house
by thousands we don't have a lot but our
house is our financial security for me
and my three children and i don't think
this is reasonable they already have an
investment as they are renting out the
current two flats already not only does
it devalue ruin our economic futures it
also significantly harms the amenities
of the surrendering residents for
instance the property is going to sit
higher than the current 17 and 18 at the
precise points that the sun comes
through to my garden 17s 19s 20s and 16s
my currently bright and sunny garden
will be in shadow and we live in the
garden we are outdoor people we grow a
huge amount of fruit trees and bushes
that we've planted ourselves we have a
vegetable plot living willow structures
play equipment and my three children and
i will no longer be able to enjoy our
outdoor space our immediacy will be
destroyed and our house an area by our
house will be overlooked it is literally
going to ruin our lives
the current 17 will have no quality of
life either and the future residents
will now have no quality of life there
is a tiny garden that currently belongs
to bottom floor flats and it is not big
enough to do a forward roll in and is
the suggestion that all four flats seven
bedrooms share this tiny plot of land or
if it is left with the current person
who has it it means that the other three
flats won't have any outdoor space
whatsoever this is not in keeping with
the community there is a safety issue i
understand that the highway said that
there wouldn't be a problem this is not
true and if you ask any residents in the
area
um this building is proposing them right
up to the boundary line on a corner on a
bend it's going to obstruct the vision
going around it it's already hard to go
around that corner vehicles park on the
side and it's restricted to one lane of
traffic there will be a head-on
collision especially now with huge
buildings sitting high up how our
children are going to see around it how
a car is going to see around it add to
that four additional car parking spaces
going in and out it's an accident
waiting to happen the six spaces won't
be enough the current two flats already
have four cars between them so the new
two flats of two bedrooms each are only
going to have a reality two spaces so
the problems out on the road will be
added to it's a nightmare
it doesn't fit in with the other houses
the committee report says that there is
little consistency and low quality
housing um i don't agree whatsoever and
neither did the two previous planning
officers with two previous applications
for smaller houses that were refused
because there wasn't enough room the
semis have a set design the terraces
have a set design and this proposal is a
complete mismatch and it doesn't fit
either it's going around a corner at two
different angles it goes right up the
boundary line and not leaving space in
the front like all the other properties
around into a corner spot with no garden
space and so it is not in keeping the
spaces are important to form the quality
of life of our neighborhood and it's
been recognized in the previous two
refusals that these spaces especially
corner blocks were valued and needed i
understand the council needs to support
growth but there are in fact 295 houses
being built three minutes down the road
and so this development adds nothing to
that
thank you thank you
thank you for listening
uh next speaker in support of the
application is nigel gail the agent
report has set out the situation well
recommends approval the site was
unsightly priced by clients purchased in
july 21. the producers have done things
around unfortunately since our plan to
clean up the site it's now starting to
feel some storm damage i understand the
fencing will be repaired shortly
i'd just like to address the reasons for
referral uh one to seven
one development has not been planned
well over development to making house 18
this coming to the terraced house
by overbearing negative impacts on the
character implants of the area
on the contrary the scheme has been well
thought out and addresses all the
concerns raised by planning during the
preamp and the planning application
process
the previous planning history of the
site was noted and we agreed with the
previous decisions and appearance to
refuse that proposed single house by the
previous owners
the character of barton tools area is
very much one of tera's two-story
dwellings
the existing semi-detached units are
themselves in congress to predominantly
terrorist former development department
tours
the reviews of the previous single house
on the cross is therefore justified and
those reasons for refusal were clearly
that is why this scheme is the two flats
in lineal form designed to turn the
corner of the street and to present a
consistent building form with the
adjacent terraces along barton's
the proposed reform was adjusted at the
suggestion of the planning officer and
we're happy to accommodate this the
visualizations that showed us well
the three there's lots of lights this
was confusing to us
there the scheme effectively turns to
semi-detached buildings into terrorist
form to match with neighbours
there's no lack of light for any of the
existing terrorist dwellings
um otherwise this would be probably
where the terrorist buildings occur
four the flats are too big and not in
keeping with the rest of the surrounding
area
we've already addressed the character of
the surrounding area which is
predominantly terrorist dwellings rather
than existing assembly transplant
the blacks are 61 meters square each
which are in accordance with the minimum
requirements of the local plan
two-bedroom three-person accommodation
six drainage southwest water happy with
the proposals
seven vehicle egress highway safety and
traffic
devon county highways
confirm they're happy with the proposals
and the proposed development offers safe
and suitable access
finally these proposals are fully
compliant with the local plan the site
is in the development boundary in a very
sustainable location it provides too
much needed two-way flats that will help
to ease the lack of likely hazardous
supply and so i asked you to improve the
application
thank you
[Music]
can you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um i just thought by saying i see
two of my fellow counselors called this
it's a big they're not here actually
i do wish council is important
um
also before i say anything else i have
to say it's one of the most powerful
statements i've heard from objective
i was very impressed with that and she
raised some points which i hadn't been
aware of because you will see that
the town council planning committee
we've turned this down twice now
in the last few months it came back to
us
and our reasons are given there and i
don't think i need to answer them
because
it struck us this was a classic caught
into a point part basically
um it really is
over development that's our main issue
that we came up with that we feel very
strongly about um so i will propose and
my town council has already asked to
turn this down
second mr chairman
[Music]
[Music]
objections and three minutes she brought
through a lot of valuable points
how can you make a privately owned
semi-detached property into indian tax
property
yeah
if our house is privately owned how can
you attach another part of the house to
it
sean can answer this
[Music]
um yeah it's a civil matter um so
there's a plastic wall act which is
outside the planning system which i'd
have to have an agreement with
so as the object to then give an
agreement for this to be done
uh in relation to all acts yes they'd
have to completely ruin the party wall
act um and it depends on how the
builders actually intending to develop
the rifts that's going to attach that
building um i believe you can show it is
detaching without the officer sorry can
i just clarify
are we talking about the extension
17
the reason why i ask is obviously the
the applicant owns number 17 so
whilst it would extend that into a
terrace
um
yeah well
that's what council lock means right
yeah currently it's a semi-detached yeah
dwelling i know there's two flats 17 and
17 eight but the building is a semi
detached
in effect did used to be just two
dwellings too
yeah do you have that well whilst i
appreciate the concerns which have been
raised by the
representation here today and also
within representations submitted in the
planet education
i think the council would consider that
it's a matter which
is not really
considered through as a planning
consideration within determination of
the application and is instead of civil
matter outside the process
sure
yeah
i think there's possibly some confusion
counselors um
yeah if we can have a look at the plan
that's on your screen at the moment to
see where the actual building is going
to be which will be attached to 1717 a
yeah which will make it a terrorist of
three dwellings so the actual attachment
is to 1717a which is owned by the um the
applicant
but the issue i think i think the issue
which has been raised is is more
you know obviously
the
person who made the representation today
owns number 18 which is obviously to the
left yeah and her concern is obviously
that she understands property and that
turning into terrorist property mailer
the value of our property which i
completely understand and appreciate
with
but as i said the reason why
it may not have been addressed and wait
maybe it shouldn't but it's not a
planning consideration it's something
that
monetary value and financial
implications are not planning
consideration and are therefore
considered in the television
[Music]
it's like somebody who buys a house with
a fantastic view over the sea and then
they lose that view
they've paid a premium to buy a house
you don't buy it with that view and the
view's gone and it's devalued and it's
not a plan initially unfortunately
and this isn't
um but i will make comment because we
put the site
or the not the site on the planet the
actual flats
because this issue about
a
they are very small i thought this when
i looked at it at home on the screen
and i think the agent did say there's a
minimum
that we would allow
a two bedroom delivery i mean look how
crap that is
the you've got the little
kitchen area in the corner a dining area
there and a lounge as well i mean it
looks awfully tiny that does to me
right yeah thanks
chair um obviously um the application
would be considered so first first off
just stay the council doesn't have any
sort of space requirements policies
itself and i think that's fair to say
usually we use you know the
technical housing space standards as a
guiding tool
61 square meters
for a two foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the other thing that concerns me is the
parking on there yeah there's no way
that you can park a car and turn it on
the site you've either got to drive on
and reverse into the road or reverse
onto it
to drive out onto
so there's no turning on the site
for the parkings so obviously um in the
assessment of this planet occasionally
various type visits and determine the
application which would normally be
considered against dcc standing advice
but on account of the application coming
to committee we saw the view of the
democrat council highways officer
he made points which i think are
relevant here
firstly is the 21 mountain road
the rogue is
has speed cushions and ramps which are
calming measures for the road equally
um
i think the natural curvature of the
rope is a preventative measure for
speeds anyway in terms of a severity
issue and then furthermore um he's
obviously looked at the collision
database which is their evidence based
for assessing the application which said
which and there hasn't been no recorded
accidents
sort of egress or accessing into
driveways in the past five years no i
think i think the issue here
your officer feels that
we have obviously consulted d60 highways
and they have come up with their
petition which is clear
and so i would
i think that this application is finding
balance and
encounters may want to refuse the
application but i would advise you
against doing it for grounds on dcc
highways the issue
of coming out on that day
even with the 29 an hour speeding it
through garden towards a
timing strategy is ridiculous to drive
out
onto that then i mean there's no
visibility for anybody coming in the
crowning of cards
it just looks a bit
it's a craft form development can i say
a lot
if we were to reviews then could we use
um
which states that the development will
be supported where it would not
significantly harm the immunities of any
neighboring occupiers or users
the question that i would ask in
reference to that is
where
[Music]
[Music]
so this is a good image i think just to
indicate the relationship of the site
with the neighboring dwellings so you've
got 16 on the left and then you've got i
don't know 16 on the right sorry and
then 17 from the left we can then
progress through to the rear the view
from from 18 so
my first question if that were the case
which is understandable
where is the harm and what harm is being
created and on who
lots of immunity space for immediate
neighbors
council craigie
i think the development
it is comes to the pavement
and
there's only time
at the back
so for four flats
there there's potentially outdoor space
at all it's all taken up by a parking
space and as you say that coffee space
right on the bend
they had to come along and
turn turn straight again
when you know there could be somebody
coming around the other way so
and i just think you know
it's it's much too big
it takes up the entire garden all the
other houses in the street have got nice
big diamonds garden
they're all family houses they don't
quite you know work housing houses but a
lot of them are brighter now they've got
lovely gardens
it's a
family area
lots of children there and um this is
going to be
like that's right in the middle of it
i don't think it's in keeping with the
area at all
well yeah that's the other issue is
detrimental to the environment the area
council christie yeah well to say thank
you to council a lot for quoting one of
the policies can we go back to the
aerial photographs
right you just
ah that's interesting because
if you look at the left
the photograph actually cuts off what's
there
there's a car park i've got it here on
my thing there's carbide it's got five
it's got a huge motorhome and four cars
in it on my screen and the photograph
was taken so what we're suggesting is
putting another load of cars the
alternate side of the road you've got a
90 degree bend with car parking outside
i'm astonished our highways think that's
acceptable
because it's ridiculous really and it's
a pity it doesn't show on that phone
drive actually
sure
[Music]
um
we've got as the officers cooperate and
said we've got the advice concession
response from the highway authority
they are the professionals in their
fields
and that's what we put weight towards
how there is a temptation and members in
the uk members to come to a different
view on that however i would just
question the reasons of that given that
we have got our full response from
democratic council highways financial
members to discuss
um in relation to discussions about
amenity and design um i've heard um
overbearing no burning um i'll just also
put members the direction of quality
dno4 which is our design principles for
that also affects immunity
and if members were going down the
direction of reviews on that basis and
there'd have to be a statement about the
reasons for that as a case officer um
was trying to articulate um and actually
where is that hardcore immunity and
development can demonstrate that i can
just think about that
um process yeah
thank you sean
councilman
yeah thank you for sharing i just come
straight back on the the highways there
obviously this
the evidence from highways is based on
previous
evidence there which doesn't include the
dwelling possibly going on the bend does
it so yeah we have no evidence for this
from here but only based on the fact
that the previous quiet road that is at
moment or quite error
and it doesn't address the problems with
the carpark or the
four new spaces or three new spaces
going into this
potential new development so you know
however you could only go on previous
compiled evidence and you know you have
to entertain new evidence now going
forward to prove
you know you know it's wrong it's wrong
that's right on the bench it is the
demonstrable effect on communities
that being
you're just trying to build on a tiny
little piece of land that's why the
houses have been
split a funny design when it comes back
in on itself you know that's why you
know you're trying to cram with it and
there's accounts of christianity
as a quarterback something like that i
certainly agree but we have to take into
consideration the comments i i take it
against consideration comments from bill
sanchez the over development of the area
you can quite clearly see that that's
the case and with the development that's
further down the road i did read
previous speaker absolutely spot on you
know there's hundreds has to go in there
this only benefits unfortunately
a small amount of people it doesn't
benefit the surrounding neighbors so
yeah even though we're looking for the
guardians etc it's another it's a block
on the landscape again and it will take
away somebody's life coming in
maybe not so much an a-team but the
previous gardens yeah
come on you'd have such a build up there
on a calculator it was and it is you
know you're looking back all these guys
in front of all these houses in front of
you and these are these houses are good
houses
you can't beat your cash lasers they're
very fantastic houses because they're a
bit well unfortunately the developments
of the day me are slums in the future
the rubbish actually is well built
and see this going in and cram it in
it's like it's like um chickens isn't it
in the battery
it's just you're just trying to cram
those people in and how many are these
are going to be seeing you know
single flats or are we going to get
families living in one bedroom places
it's going to be crammed up in here and
the movement of traffic is going to be
absolutely longer i think so
i thought it very exciting
it's been moved through future by
council christie
seconded by became
and for me it's the immunity
impact on our energy which is the
emerald one
and i always access and parking
notwithstanding what the highways
officer may have said about it
um
it doesn't adversely impact the local
roads as far as i'm concerned it does
with that parking on the corner to
reverse out from there
or to reverse into it right on the bed
it's just ludicrous
anybody can
say that that's a safe way of
doing it and the lack of immunity not
just for residents in the area but for
the absolute people living in 17 and 17
eight and the proposed they got
so for those two reasons so just to
confirm is it the lack of a means of
space for the uh for the future
[Music]
the impact
those would be the three planning policy
reasons
sg10
we don't agree
we think it does affect adversely the
local road roadway
uh dmo one and dm4 don't get three
please to refuse
thank you chair
[Music]
or unanimous chair to refuse
thank you chandra
thank you ryan
105
105 sure
this application has been brought to
plans committee because it is on tdc
owned land so um the application is for
the installation of 27.5 meter high
ground-based lattice tower with
associated associated ambulances and
equipment and cabinets they're also
going to be putting the lighting on
which is the existing lighting that's on
the existing travel that's there at the
moment
um and then ancillary equipment and
cabling
i'm counseling luxury
so this is the location plan so it is on
the existing site where there's already
a 27.5 meter lattice tower so it's kind
of a replacement so
you'll be able to see it from kingsley
road obviously the accesses through
through the strand kind of vehicular
access
um it is a mix of residential commercial
um and obviously you've got the the
football ground right next to it
this is just show the existing site plan
at the moment so there is already a
lattice tower there and associated
equipment
for the for the site
so this is the the tower that's already
there so there is no increase in height
it's still going to be 27 and a half
meters which is already on the site and
the next few plans are just kind of
panning around the side so you can see
morrison's kind of in the background
that's kind of the bottom of the tower
where the equipment and chain link fit
fences already and that's all just going
to to be replicated
there we go so that's looking north east
and then that's just looking back at
morrisons again and then
carry on so yeah so that's looking to
obviously the two further glasses towers
that are to the north and if we can
round
obviously you've got the football field
and the
seating area and then obviously to the
northwest you've also got another
lattice house there's four on site
already like i say this is just a
replacement at the same height
so this is just showing the proposed
site plan obviously it's quite in detail
because there's kind of quite small
cabinets for it obviously it is to
improve connectivity for the whole of
benefit in terms of telecommunications
and if we just look to show these that's
the existing elevations
and then the next slide is the proposed
so same height um
we've had no objections and no
representations received um for the
application
so just to say the main considerations
are principle of development impact on
character and appearance impact on
neighbouring community ecology
and the critical drainage area as i said
no representations have been received
environmental
protection had comments um on their
first response um but more information
was provided and then on their second
response they had no objections so it is
recommended for approval
jim i can't
that one there so it's next to the flats
at the strand
so that's the one that's been the best
i'll i'll propose that we have checked
this
thank you thanks for watching
country questions last question um
down back in a while now but um there
were there was a problem with the rent
from the football club
and
[Music]
the payment
that the company were making for the
mathematics was came direct to us
now if they're putting up a better marks
with presuming more telephone
connections on it are we going to charge
them more because
it does come to us i think
well it's not a planning it's not
planning but it's an interesting one
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
secondly
wants to
[Music]
[Music]
councilmember golf or
cancer watson or councillor wiseman or
unanimous chair to grants
what worth waiting for
right now we can move on to a gender
item
[Music]
so you see there are two
two appeals on 105 there one
was allowed and one was dismissed yeah
sentence was dismissed there also
council chris smiles about page one away
[Music]
he's got the most worrying thing i've
seen in years
the flood maps are incorrect
uh
they've not changed the map to explain
why they've not been checked
and it's about flood levels now
flood levels have a major impact on
insurance payments by people who are
living along the key and i'm just amazed
at the environment agency oh yeah
they're wrong but we're not doing it but
i mean i think we need to chase this up
and ask the environment to see
how their maps wrong
are they going to re-survey them
you've no information i've got no
information but we can chase
[Music]
all right well
yeah that should be a decision we move
on to nine which is costs on appeal
uh you'll see that
no cops have been awarded on any of the
appeals against accountants
is the delegated
agm applications a generation
pages 119.
i will just say on this one because
in a way it
refers back in a way to the film bond
these agriculture this is permitted
developing these
hemp
applications in the name but they are
sustainability never comes seems to come
into these you know there are
agricultural
museum conversions or derelict farm
buildings
out in the countryside not in
sustainable locations
which i don't object to because i like
to see youth and made use of but it just
seems a bit of an
anomaly
that in some instances it's all right to
have
something out in the countryside
converted to residential use whereas as
we looked at the one earlier it didn't
fit with our
sustainability policies like i said
right at the start these policies
where we start considering all the
applications from
are
very subjective in many ways and can be
interpreted in various ways and if you
read them carefully as a written
they can be interpreted in different
ways there's kind of lockdown laws i can
see it looking
11 on the agenda for the planning
decisions made between the 24th of
february on the 31st of march pages 120
228.
i've got nothing to bring up this time
the fifth one down remove the stopped
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
i'll declare the meeting closely